eh A través de los datos del Instituto
Mexicano de la competitividad que es una
ong que mide eh eh los avances en
políticas públicas aquí en México eh
durante el año 2017 al 2000 al 2021 eh
el el uso de renovables aumentó en un
26.4%. este dato es muy importante para
ver que la política de la reforma
energética el año 2013 que se llevó a
cabo aquí en México pues da una
perspectiva bastante amplia contra a lo
que ha sucedido últimamente con estos
frenos legales que han ocurrido
últimamente en México
como estábamos diciendo en la
introducción a su presentación el estado
de Sonora podría convertirse en una
suerte de Polo verde no de energías
alternativas qué detalles se conocen
sobre este proyecto Y por qué se elige a
esta región en particular
bueno esta región en particular tiene un
alto grado de insulación es decir tiene
un una un potencial energético en
materia de energía solar bastante
importante dado que el Estado Sonora es
un estado con una amplitud geográfica
bastante grande es el segundo en mayor
en territorio en México Además de que
este territorio es es desértico entonces
tiene prácticamente 300 días de sol al
año es la razón sin embargo hay que
hacer una acotación de que esta esta
situación no está del todo planeada no
está del todo detallado dado que Sonora
también tiene graves problemas de
interconexión al sistema eléctrico
nacional y de igual manera tiene un
aislamiento natural en este sentido
Entonces si hay una una una serie de
obstáculos todavía técnicos y de
desarrollo en el en la planeación del
proyecto porque se tienen que que salvar
y bueno este proyecto Pues todavía tiene
muchísimo muchísimo de qué hablar y de
qué trabajarse
en tan solo 30 a 40 segundos pero no
quiero dejar de realizarle la siguiente
pregunta que es Cómo son los vínculos
entre México y Estados Unidos en materia
energética y si pueden complementarse
para alcanzar este objetivo que
comparten como decíamos
en este bueno en este momento es
bastante complicado hablar de la de la
relación energética entre México y
Estados Unidos dado que estamos en medio
de un conflicto internacional derivado
de las políticas públicas de el
presidente López Obrador contra lo que
se tiene realmente dicho entonces
Finalmente y con esto concluyó se en la
política se dicen muchas cosas pero en
los hechos y en la política pública En
el gobierno mexicano realmente vamos
para atrás incluso voy a cerrar con un
pequeño dato en donde la Comisión
Federal de Electricidad aumenta un 55%
el uso de Carbón lejos se ve esto